i can't get this look like influencer
oatmeal
hey turn on the hidden levels and the
grid
[Music]
okay sorry about that i have to film
things by myself so that's
what i had to do in recent years apple
has integrated
new features into the default iphone
camera app that allow you to take much
better
photos and videos you just have to know
where to look
so i haven't covered the best of these
new features and all you need is an
iphone they can run ios 14. there's one
tip
where you have to have an iphone 12 pro
and if you don't skip by it but
if you're curious check it out anyways
tip one hidden camera levels
ah the elusive squared up top-down shot
seen so often in food photography note
how straight the horizontal and vertical
lines are
the iphone now makes getting these types
of photos easy by using its
accelerometer
first you need to enable the grid do
this by going to settings
camera and toggling on the grid
then simply hold your phone straight
down to trigger the crosshair to come up
now when the crosshair is inside the
yellow one that's when you've got your
shot
tip number two quick video capture you
know the dance you want to quickly
capture video but you miss the moment
because you're swiping over to the video
setting
now there's a simple gesture that allows
you to quickly take video and photos at
the same time
when you're taking a video with your
phone hold on the shutter and you can
start recording video
drag upward or to the right depending on
your orientation
tap the shutter button here to keep
snapping photos during the video too
tip number three burst mode sometimes
you don't want a video but instead a
rapid sequence of photos aka
burst mode tap and hold the shutter then
quickly drag it toward the camera roll
square a counter will appear showing you
the number of images taken in the burst
[Music]
want to use the volume up button to take
burst shots
go to settings camera
and use volume up for bursts
tip number four preserve creative
controls
with preserved creative controls if you
change a setting like a photo's aspect
ratio
say from 16 by nine to a square image
then close the camera and reopen it it
won't revert back to the default
it will stay out what you set it in this
case a square image go to settings
camera preserve settings then toggle on
the slider for creative controls
tip number five reveal exposure control
in the past dialing and exposure was a
fussy experience tapping and sliding
every which way
now you can control exposure and the
mood of your photos a bit more easily
open your camera tap the carrot at the
top of the screen to reveal your
controls drawer
tap here to reveal the exposure control
slider
drag it to the left and right to dial in
the look you prefer
tip number six 24 frames per second
video recording
many films and popular tv shows are
shown at 24 frames per second
now you too can easily achieve the
cinema standard for your home videos or
random shots of people in a park to set
your videos to 24 frames per second
tap settings camera
record video then select your preferred
resolution at 24 frames per second you
can easily change recording formats now
too without going into your iphone
settings just tap in the top corner and
select your frame rate and resolution of
choice
tip 7 the mirror selfie
ah the mirror selfie when you're taking
a selfie you see your mirrored self in
the viewfinder
and you become familiar with that person
but then the finished pitcher is this
unmirrored other guy
i am not a fan of unmirrored kenny i
kind of hate him and he's not who i'm
used to seeing
mirrored kenny on the other hand who i'm
familiar with i'm a fan
to get rid of your unmirred self and
turn this on go to settings
camera and under composition toggle on
mirror front camera
and finally tip 8 apple pro roth
this feature is currently only available
on the iphone 12 pro models
if that's not you feel free to skip
ahead apple pro raw is a new setting
that lets you shoot in raw and is
available in
ios 14.3 it lets you get the absolute
best photos out of your iphone
it captures more information about the
photo in a highly editable
dng file compared to default compress
images like jpeg or heif photos which
are around two to six megabytes each
a dmg can be upward of 25 megabytes
because of that size you'll want to use
these sparingly for your most important
moments
so why is it worth it raw images allow
you to recover detail and shadows and
highlights without the image breaking
apart as much
note here how much detail is lost in the
shadows of the jpeg
compared to the raw you no longer need a
special app to edit raw photos and you
can just use the photos app like you
would with any other photo
but i've been using the free app here
snapseed which is pretty great
enable apple pro raw by tapping settings
camera
formats then toggling on apple prora
now when you open the camera a raw
button will appear in the top corner
tap that to enable apple pro raw now go
out and take some great instagram photos
use that iphone camera
the best of its abilities because what
else is there to do right now cloning
myself in videos
cloning myself
there's somebody right there there's
nobody there
i'm losing it